hello everyone and welcome to a video
that's not really a video in itself but
uh rather an extension on the previous
video where we showed the game between
the video and yani pognishi
uh where we said what have we what kind
of happened in this whole uh fuss about
defeating online chess olympiad but we
were
well i was missing some facts as i rely
too much on twitter
uh for what what actually happens in the
world but like i said when we will have
an official statement from fiji i will
uh keep you guys informed so here is the
official statement from fide regarding
what happened uh let's
just enlarge this a little bit so this
this was posted yesterday india and
russia declared joint winners of the
online
vhs olympiad and while this is the
part that we've covered after a 3-3 tie
in the first round where all six games
ended in a draw the second end
decisive match was impacted by a global
internet outage so it was not a problem
uh with the internet connection of only
some of the players but actually
it was a global internet outage that
severely affected many countries
including
india uh two of the indian players nihal
sarin and diva deshmukh
lost connection towards the end of the
game subsequently losing on time
the incident happened when three games
ended in draws and the outcome of the
match was still
unclear as a result russia was initially
proclaimed the winner of the match after
being adjudicated a victory by four and
a half to one and a half in the second
round
however india appealed the result on the
grounds that their players along
with hundreds of other users were logged
out of chess.com as
as a consequence of a massive internet
outage uh at
the time of the games as soon as the
last game between guriacan and hampi
konero was over
uh goriachina won in a long battle in a
rook end game
india appealed the match uh the match
results on the grounds that their
players uh
okay we already said that along with
hundreds of others we're logged out of
chess.com as a consequence of a massive
internet outage at the time of uh the
games
uh the appeals committee examined all
the evidence provided by chess.com as
well as information gathered from other
sources about
the cloud flare crash that caused the
outage
after being informed of their
considerations and in absence of a
unanimous very
verdict defeat a president made the
decision to award gold medals to both
teams so the
uh the committee couldn't reach a
unanimous decision so arkady vorkovich
had had to break the tie it is very
unfortunate
that technical difficulties got in the
way of the final until that moment the
match between india and russia had
been one of the most thrilling and
balanced uh scene in the 2020 online
chess olympiad
in the first round like we mentioned all
games ended in draw but it was actually
a narrow escape
by russia as india was clearly pressing
for a match win
uh virita nipomnishi the game we've
shown yesterday uh engaged in a fight in
one of the sharpest lines of the
groomfield defense and
just when vidi seemed to be very close
to launching a decisive attack
uh jan found a jaw-dropping resource
that sacrifice on uh
of the rook on f2 one could call the pla
the whole plan a gamble
and probably the engines will give a
sentence that the move was not correct
but
chess is a sport especially rapid chess
and the counter attack by the russian
star posed too many problems for his
opponent
nippon she created very serious threats
uh and it was
vedic who go who had to go for the
perpetual check
uh then here uh fide addresses the the
match with between hampi canary and
katarina
saying that also they went for a sharp
groomful line that evolved into a very
unbalanced position hampi was
an exchange up but her pawn structure
was destroyed and
had the bishop pair later on the game
was transformed into an ending where the
indian
had two rooks against the queen hampi
was clearly winning but with an exposed
king and being in severe time trouble
she failed to escape the perpetual check
by lucknow
and the game ended in a threefold
repetition uh regarding alexander
costano she was probably the only
russian player who enjoyed a favorable
position in the first round
she came out of the opening with a with
the pair of bishops and better piece
placement and with a steady hand she
took the game
to a better ending it was probably the
right decision but the end game
advantage proved to be uh more difficult
to convert than it seemed at first and
the game ended in a draw the sixth in
the match so the second round started
with important changes in both themes
uh india threw anand into the battle
vidit moved to
uh board two replacing hari krishna and
nihal sareen replaced pragnanda
on the russian side the dub of guriacan
and esipenko replaced
artemis and saranac respectively anand
played a very solid game against
impromishing probably as a part of the
team's strategy where india put its
hopes
mainly on the lower boards uh vidit
playing with white accepted upon
sacrifice by dubois an ingenious plan
that allowed black to quickly activate
his pieces and get a very comfortable
play
the two top boards ended in a draw uh
then they mentioned alexander
goriashkina scored
the only victory for the russian team
against hampi canero the runner-up of
the 2020 women's world championship
played a good game where she obtained an
advantage and once again demonstrated
her excellent technique this game was
affected by connectivity issues
as hampi got disconnected and even
though she could reconnect before the
time
ran out she lost some very valuable time
two other games were affected by the
same issues
came to that that were affected by the
same issues came to an abrupt end
at the moment of disconnection nihal
sarin was defending his grounds against
andrey sipenko who enjoyed a certain
advantage at the girls board of diva
deshmukh
was on the verge of a victory against
paulina shuvalova
it was just a matter of time until a
decisive attack can be launched under
the time control
uh having an attack against the king is
likely uh being one pawn up
joked kramnik about the position of this
game uh the engines
actually value the position plus two in
white's favor so
with one of the two games very likely to
be an indian victory the match seemed
destined to be decided again in an
armageddon game
but the incident with the disconnection
did not let it happen the ensuing
decision
under these unprecedented circum
circumstances
was to award gold medal to both teams uh
even if
shared this can be considered the first
victory of india
in a chess olympiad and the first one
for russia since 2002. and here
we have the official statement by fide
president arkady dworkovic
the one we were we were waiting for uh
the online chess olympiad has been
impacted by a global internet outage
that severely affected several countries
uh including india two of the indian
players have been affected and lost
connection
when the outcome of the match was still
unclear the appeals committee has
examined all the evidence provided by
chess.com as well as information
gathered from other sources about the
internet outage
after being informed of their
considerations and in abscess of a
unanimous decision
and taken into account these
unprecedented circumstances
uh as feed a president i made the
decision to award gold medals
to both teams so that there you have it
that's the official statement by fide
and regarding uh the matter of uh
uh also uh armenia filing an appeal
uh and the lebanon being very very
unhappy about a similar thing that
happened to armenia here fide also
addresses that
uh they said that following the
disconnection of hike martirossi and the
armenian team
filed an official appeal that was
rejected by the appeals committee formed
by federal president arkadie work which
michael kodakowski
and savastoy which not satisfied with
the decision armenia defaulted the
second match
and as a result india is through to the
semi-finals so that's why of course
armenians were very unhappy and here you
can see the appeals committee resolution
here so here
fida addresses uh why they declined
declined armenia's appeal uh the appeals
committee considered the protest of the
armenian team against
the result of the first match of the
india armenia quarter-final
in this match the game between nikhil
salini and hike martyrossen was
considered a defeat for the armenian
team
after its player got disconnected
according to the regulations of the
event which were discussed in detail
with team captains the quality and
stability of the internet connection is
the sole responsibility of the players
so if you have a bad connection that's
your fault if something happens if
it's your fault unless there's like a
global outage like in the
uh in the case of the india russia uh
but also there is
something very interesting here uh the
appeals committee would like to point
out
that as a general rule section two of
the blah blah blah uh the quality of the
internet connection is the
responsibility of the player
including its uh reliability and
stability the practice of applying this
point
during the olympiad has been already
established in previous incidents
among other examples the indian national
team the current rival of armenia in
this match lost two games in a match
with the mongolian team precisely for
reasons of the quality of the internet
thus in order to overcome this
presumption the evidence of the site's
guilt must be direct and prove the guilt
beyond
any doubt no other reliable evidence of
problems on the game server was
presented
to the appeals committee in addition to
the general conclusion provided by the
armenian team
the appeals committee also noted that
there were problems with the quality of
the internet in one of the other games
of the match where the normal course of
the game was restored
three minutes after the failure no
appeal was filed by any of the teams in
this case
in the game being considered as part of
the appeal the armenian player had about
50 seconds to restore the connection
which turned out to be insufficient in
the current situation any other decision
would be in
incas inconsistent with the tournament
regulations
creating a precedent that could lead to
further conflicting situations the
appeals committee also finds that any
other decision would be unfair to the
opposing team
in view of this the appeals committee
decided to reject the appeal of the
armenian team the armenian team will not
be
charged charged for presenting this
appeal uh somewhere somewhere i
read uh i don't know if it was here but
uh supposedly the
armenian team uh when they lost
connection uh with
with the server their zoom uh their zoom
conver
you know their zoom uh i was still on
so it's not like they lost internet they
just lost connection to the server
now i'm i'm not uh my knowledge on these
things is the world
average at best so if someone uh maybe
who is more tech savvy can shed some
light on this
is it possible to lose like uh
connection to the server
but not uh for your for example zoom
call to be interrupted
and that that it's still your fault and
not the the site's fault
i don't know it sounds sounds very weird
uh but
this is fida's official statement about
how they handle the situation uh
regarding the india uh india's match
with uh
armenia and also why uh arkady vorkovich
declared what he did regarding the
finals of the 2020 video online olympiad
uh between uh india and russia so there
you have it uh
shedding some light on the matter like
we said we will after a fee day
uh gives the uh official statement so
all in all
it's i mean uh when we shifted
everything to the you know online
environment of course uh things like
this will happen and we don't have
anything in the rules that uh you know
uh can prepare us for such things of
course
uh they they made some arrangements
before the actual tournaments and
they are improving them all the time uh
but sometimes uh
i mean what if the entire world loses
the internet for like half an hour what
so what do we do then do we just punish
the players
if they were on the move and they lost
on time or do we
repeat the entire match all six boards
uh for example
i don't know if uh okay here in this
case it was
the the result of the match was unclear
but what would be the decision if for
example
uh three of the boards were winning or
maybe if
uh you know five boards was five boards
that already made a draw and on one
board
i don't know one player had a mating one
when the outage happened i mean
it's a very tricky situation and i don't
see it being resolved
easily in online environment uh but uh
that's i mean that's
what this is this is an online event and
should not have uh you know
the the same uh i don't know how how to
put it maybe the
the same importance as as an actual live
you know in in person event uh as
things like this just uh it will happen
and
i i don't think we still have the
technology to you know
make sure that and none of this ever
happens uh but
uh that's basically it uh that's uh
fida's official statement i do hope you
enjoyed it like i said this isn't
a video this is just an extension on the
previous video uh so
uh thank you for watching have an
excellent start of your week and
i will see you soon continuing the
morphe saga and whatever else happens
in the chess world thank you and see you
soon guys